At the end of September, Amazon Prime Video
will make sure its subscribers are ready for
Halloween.
The last day of the month will see the addition
of scary flicks like Cloverfield, Event Horizon,
and Tales from the Darkside: The Movie.
Maybe because of the big influx, Prime isn't
adding quite as many movies and TV shows in
October, but what the line-up lacks in quantity,
it makes up for in quality.
As of October 2019, the Amazon Prime original
Goliath will be three years old.
"I hate you very much."
"I hate you too, honey."
The first season of the legal drama starring
Billy Bob Thornton as a washed-up lawyer seeking
to atone for past mistakes premiered in October
2016.
Fans had to wait two years for a second season,
and fortunately, they only had to wait half
the time for a third.
At the end of October, the 1993 crime film
Killing Zoe is heading to Prime Video.
Eric Stoltz stars in this American-French
film in the vein of early Quentin Tarantino
films of the time.
Earlier in the month, however, we'll get a
decidedly different kind of film.
October 1st brings the 2009 animated film
Astro Boy to Prime.
Astro Boy follows the adventures of a young
boy who's killed, and then resurrected as
a robot superhero.
It may have been tough at first to imagine
John Krasinski as an action hero, but Prime's
original Jack Ryan changed that in a big way
when Krasinski took on the role of Tom Clancy's
most recognizable protagonist.
Jack Ryan isn't the first time the hero has
been adapted to the screen.
Harrison Ford played the CIA analyst twice,
beginning with the espionage thriller Patriot
Games, which is set to arrive on Prime on
October 1st.
In this 1992 film, Ryan is thrust into the
role of hero when — while on vacation in
London — he witnesses an attack on members
of the English royal family.
Ryan — who'd left the CIA before the events
of the film — returns to his former job
so he can take the reins of the efforts to
capture the terrorist.
"I will put such a strange hold on your gun
money that you'll be out on the street throwing
rocks."
Adding to the already long list of horror
titles being added to Prime at the end of
September, October 3rd brings High Life to
the streaming service.
Starring Robert Pattinson and Juliette Binoche,
High Life is a sci-fi/horror film following
a group of convicts sent to explore a Black
Hole.
Haley Joel Osment, who initially won widespread
recognition as the boy who could "see dead
people" in M. Night Shyamalan's The Sixth
Sense, has been enjoying some prominent roles
in recent series like Future Man and The Boys.
But if you'd like a chance to see him back
when he was beardless, Prime offers the chance
on October 1st, when it adds Steven Spielberg's
A.I.
Artificial Intelligence to its library.
Set in the not-too-distant future, A.I. is
about a young robot boy whose programming
somehow allows for the capacity to love.
Jude Law stars alongside Osment as Gigolo
Joe, a robot sex worker on the run.
While Prime's original Goliath brings us a
fresh mystery in October, later in the month,
the streaming service will add the third season
of the British crime drama Unforgotten, which
focuses on mysteries so old that everyone
else has given up on them.
In Unforgotten's third season, Detective Chief
Inspector Cassie Stuart and her partner Sunny
tackle a case almost two decades old.
"DCI Cass Stuart and DI Sunny Khan."
When workers on a highway uncover the remains
of a 16 year old girl who was reported missing
in 2000, it gets the heroes' attention.
Unforgotten's fourth season has been confirmed,
and it's likely for release either later this
year or in 2020.
If you're a Prime subscriber looking to get
caught up for the upcoming season, this looks
like the perfect opportunity.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.